now comes the segment show that is some
of youse favorite and then he went
include James and Kelly in the booth
booster an associate producer they like
when other people say mean things about
me because I see mean things to them all
the time so it's fair I guess but not
really
so yeah they collect these over several
weeks and then I get to read them
they're called mean tweets people say
mean crap about me on the Internet
and on the on the Twitter and account
and James thinks it's funny so he
collects them and then I get to read
them and they're really kind of fall
into two categories if you didn't know
by the way great news aside from the
mean tweets I just found out the meeting
this morning we had our three millionth
high school student graduate from Dave
Ramsey's foundations and personal
finance three million high school
students have now been through that one
in three high schools 34 percent of the
high schools in America are teaching
this curriculum consequently there are a
lot of students sitting in class that
are supposed to be studying but no they
are tweeting about Dave I found this out
the hard way years ago I this kid
tweeted something and I just wrapped her
man I went back at her I thought it was
a full-grown woman and I thought you you
test pilot for a broom Factory I'm
getting after you you know and I and
then I found that it's this
fourteen-year-old kid man and I turned
all my all my Twitter followers I mean
seven or thousand people are pouncing on
this poor kid and I had to go back on
they're gay it's a kid it's a kid I
found out later
back off ever don't kill her I'm sorry I
turned you loose on her oh so we have
students mean tweets and then we have
old people mean tweets I was going to
say adults but I'm not sure based on
some of these tweets that that's the
case so talking about emotional
intelligence anyway all right so John
who is a teacher tweeted student just
said in class
you know Dave Ramsey wears the same
thing in every video you'd think he
could afford more than one shirt yes
that's been said before hell Jake
tweeted I will not let Dave Ramsey ruin
my attitude for the rest of the good for
you Jake
Emily 20 tweeted I wish someone looked
at me like Miss shoemaker looks at Dave
Ramsey Oh teacher crash Rebecca I hate
doing Dave Ramsey stuff in class I get
it I'm 18 I'm poor Cameron says I'm
tired of Dave Ramsey always telling me
how to live my life well there you go
Cameron it's been happening a long time
baby flex there's a Twitter handle for
you I'm little scared about what that
might mean from a teenager Dave Ramsey
root runs a get-rich-quick scheme thank
you baby flex no gonna get rich slow
scheme Emma said I'd like to thank Dave
Ramsey not only for his shameless sexism
but also for his ignorance of white
privilege and socio-economic disparity
this from a kid that's a teenager with
an iPhone in her head yeah which makes
you tech um expert on socio-economic
disparity okay quasis
hate you dave ramsey but i love you at
the same time homeboy okay you got it
quite Caitlyn says what high school
student wants to watch Dave Ramsey the
rest the week at school Taylor says
watching a Dave Ramsey video and to be
honest it was scarier than a church
service yeah I don't know where you're
going to church do but that's scary all
right other mean tweets from old people
not students Mike mission accomplished
Dave Ramsey blocked me which means I
don't have to read his pulp on
entitlements when you guys retweeted
cool that's good
well it would have been easy easier to
just not follow me in the first place
doofus
Oh Lord Travis says I hope Dave Ramsey
burns in the deepest and darkest circle
of hell
well there you go how kind of warming up
right now Steve set learning about Dave
Ramsey is kind of terrifying
it's almost literally a religion based
on wealth no it's a Christian who reads
the Bible Ames as Dave Ramsey is the
most annoying little bald man I've ever
seen in my whole life
little usually isn't something that
people throw at me they usually say big
but anyways that's not good annoying you
I get that one Caleb says I feel like
Dave Ramsey just opens his closet and
it's nothing but blue dress shirts brown
belts and jeans and maybe head polish
that's what my wife was saying this
morning she said you need class she
didn't say anything about the head
polish though okay that's funny uh
Shelby said
jarrod and I listened to Dave Ramsey the
hallway to Arizona and we are pretty
much now seventy years old yeah it is
you like like going blight speed you
know great grant Dave Ramsey is like a
bald Colonel Sanders with a country
accent Sanders had a country accent okay
yeah uh Leanna said Dave Ramsey has all
the money in the world but he's still
wearing a blue cotton cotton button-up
from Walmart some Wrangler jeans and
Crocs well clothes you know it didn't
come from Walmart and I don't want my
Crocs in awhile but I could get them
back out I guess and Sierra says Dave
Ramsey you're a savage oh yes no doubt
there's your main tweet segment for the
Dave Ramsey show James's week is now
made he feels much better
he feels justified now and he will
continue to collect your craziness right
before I block you
yes so it's so tickles me so much to
Twitter is such a dumb thing because you
know it's like it's a voluntary thing
you select who you want to follow and
you know like I don't want to follow
some left-wing nut you know and so I
don't follow left wing nuts
I don't follow right wing nuts for that
matter um but I mean I follow people
that I want to know what they say I
don't follow people that when they say
what I know they're going to say it
pisses me off I don't get it that you
people want to use masochistic your
Twitter masochist yeah that's what it is
you you want to bring pain into your own
life because it somehow gives you I
don't fulfillment or something I know
it's weird but anyway it's a it's it's
voluntary just don't follow and some but
you know so I just block the crap out of
people they unless they start this stuff
the you know cussing like crazy I just
block them I'm not reading that trash or
just ripping me to shreds for no
apparent reason
oh wow why do I want to read I'm gonna
read that I just block what I'm not
gonna let you follow me there you go
just like that
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 income
you